hey we might be late to the party but at
least we came
strong baby stronger than the people who
beat us to the upload button with a
better written list
well as our writing department would
like to believe we give you the best
animator for 2020
cue the music
we kick start this list with another
webtoon turned anime
noblies the story revolves around rye a
noblese
aka a pure bloody chad who awakens from
his 820 year slumber
his servant frankenstein enrolls him at
yiran high school
where rai will learn the simple and
quotidian routines of the human world
through his classmates
however his conscious days get gradually
disrupted by the cause of the union a
group equivalent to the illuminati in
the novelist universe
they're a mighty secret organization
with strings around the globe and a goal
to rule the world
it's worth mentioning unlike its webtoon
predecessor nobody's actually had an
animated adaptation in the form of ova
in 2015 and ona in 2016
so if you can't wait to get your food
served and not a reader then those two
episodes are the only way to help you
ease the hunger
from the creators of angel beats in 2010
and
charlotte in 2015 we have the day i
became a god
at the end of the last summer vacation
of high school yuta
narukami spends his days preparing for
the university entrance exams
when a young guild named hina suddenly
appears proclaiming herself as the god
of omniscience
yuta is confused and doesn't believe her
especially after telling him that the
world will end after 30 days
which is highly understandable i suppose
i mean why would you believe
such a claim without evidence to back it
up it would be like as if i'm telling
you that i am a trap
but would you believe that hearing my
chad british voice without seeing me
surely you wouldn't believe that would
you what i'm trying to say here is you
can't
blame the dude if the world did end
god i never thought this day would ever
come
next we have a returning classic
higurashi
when they cry new this version is the
remastered adaptation of the visual
novels
and for people who are new to anime and
not familiar with this title
don't let the cute anime girls fool you
when they cry is a horror classic
not a moe show not in the slightest
tagged mystery
horror psychological supernatural and
thriller
this show definitely ain't a pony ride
right so the third season of dungeon
knee
dee oh this man the third season of is
it wrong to pick up girls in a dungeon
is back
and i trust by now 80 of you are
familiar with the plot
while some of you eager fans know it
like the back of your hand because
you've rewatched it multiple times
because of all the delays that keep on
happening
so there's no need to recite the plot
here all you need to know is that the
show is finally back with its third
season picking up the action
and from the looks of it in the trailer
monitor killing thought slaying funny
bone
bill will finally truly pick up a girl
in a dungeon
next we have a new show called jiu-jitsu
kaizen
now i don't know about you but that
ladies and gentlemen
is a great title jiu-jitsu alone is an
awesome word
and to put it with kaizen which i found
out after a quick google search means
decanted from the vigilante one i mean
come on man that's
awesome and i wish i could say the same
for the plot however
the jujitsu kaizen plot doesn't feel
that special demons feed on unsuspecting
humans
fragments of a legendary and feared
demon were lost and scattered all over
the place
which by the way is practically
littering but the government
don't have to get involved because
demons are searching for them
not to clean the streets god no it's to
eat them
and gain power that can destroy the
world but
thankfully a mysterious school of
jujitsu sorcerer is trying to prevent
that while protecting the precarious
existence of the living from the undead
now it might not sound so special but
what's special about it is the character
design
as well as the animation which felt
pretty cool to me at least
so hopefully like the title it will turn
out to be something awesome
it a mysterious immortal being is sent
to the earth with no emotions nor
identity
however it's able to take the shape of
those around it that have a strong
impetus sounds familiar right at first
it's a sphere then it imitates the form
of a rock
as the temperature drops and the snow
falls atop the moss it
inherits the shape of a moss then wolf
and so on
then it gains consciousness and begins
to wander the empty cold land until
it meets a boy now acquiring the form of
the boy
it sets off on another never-ending
journey in search of new experiences
places and people now although the
premise sounds like the beginning of
that time i got reincarnated as a slime
i feel like to your eternity is going to
be
uniquely good knowing that the creator
of a silent voice is behind the new show
so i couldn't be anything more than
hyped
next the son of a classic show or rather
the daughter of a classic show
yasha a princess half demon said in
feudal japan
half demon twins dovah and setsuna are
separated from each other during a
forest fire
while desperately searching for her
younger sister dawa wanders into a
mysterious tunnel that sends her into
present-day japan
where she's found and raised by kargomei
higurashi's brother
ten years later the tunnel that connects
the two ears has reopened
allowing thora to be reunited with
setsuna who's now
a demon slayer but to thor satsuna
appears to have lost all memories of her
older sister
joined by maroha the daughter of
inuyasha and kagome
the three young women travel between the
two eras on an adventure to regain their
missing past
yasha he princess half demon follows the
daughters of seshumaru and inuyasha
well from the looks of it the anime gods
have smiled down on us
giving us back some of the classics like
when they cry bleach
shaman king and now inuyasha well
kind of
let's continue our list with mahoka koko
no
rahosha hen i swear to god man these
japanese titles
shiba classmate kitayama shizuku is on
her way to study abroad
now for magicians this is normally
impossible since allowing the genes of
someone who can use magic outside their
home country's borders is equivalent to
giving up national secrets
so in other words lads if you decide to
mingle with these fictional characters
according to their universe laws
it might be an act of war but it is
allowed to happen in one case
exchange programs and that's how
angelina
ends up in japan around the time lena
arrived in japan magicians began getting
attacked by a mysterious being who
leaves his victims drained of blood
now i'm not a detective but coincidence
i think not no [ __ ] sherlock
next we have the third season of golden
kamui
after the events of the first and second
season we're expecting
some characters to reunite once again
the third season might cover the sarcasm
in which tsugimoto heads further north
and encounters a new rival golden karma
season 3 is scheduled to air in october
and last but not least coming back in
the fall of 2020
is the second season of haikyuu to the
top
it's also scheduled to air in october it
picks up after the events of the first
half after leaving us hanging in the
middle of the nationals
so my question to you my viewer who's
watched the show are you ready to fly
once again
with hinata and with that we end this
list
hope you had a great time fellas if you
did then why not like this video
and also since you've stayed here till
this point my dear unsubscribed viewer
why not continue your good deeds and
subscribe now until
next upload gentlemen